[Music]
whether they came from veteran actors at
the height of their career or Rising
Stars taken too soon last words can
leave an impact on many these are some
of the most heart-wrenching final
exchanges actors have shared with their
late co-stars Desi Ares was as big as
they come throughout his acting career
which spanned from 1940 until his final
film role in 1982's The Escape Artist
more famously arnes was recognized for
being the lead in the groundbreaking
1950s sitcom I Love Lucy along side his
then wife Lucille Ball the pair met on
the set of the film too many girls and
eloped during the movie's production
together a couple filmed more than 180
episodes of I Love Lucy while going on
to make films and special appearances I
think if it would have been for Lucy I
would have stopped trying a long time
ago because I was always the guy that
didn't fit unfortunately the world's
most famous couple of the time divorced
in 1960 and shared few exchanges until
arnes was on his deathbed in 1986 the
2022 documentary Lucy and Desi revealed
many truths about the Hollywood couple
including their final words to each
other according to their daughter Lucy
arnes she reunited her parents to have
one last conversation on their wedding
anniversary November 30th 1986 realizing
ares's time was limited the former
partners spoke on the phone ball
reportedly exclaimed her love for her
former co-star and he replied in kind
arnes passed away 2 Days Later most
famous for performing ridiculous
Daredevil acts as a regular cast member
on jackass MTV reports that Ryan Dunn
was known as the cast member willing to
take on stunts even the likes of steo
wouldn't a longtime member of The Troop
Dunn was undeniably closest with star
Bam Margera since the pair had worked
alongside each other in the jackass
predecessor series CKY unfortunately in
2011 Dunn and his production assistant
Zachary Hartwell died in an alcohol
involved vehicular accident in Chester
County Pennsylvania torn up about the
loss of his friend marera spoke about
the accident with e- news a short time
later he called dun his best friend and
explained that he was still in extreme
pain over the loss 5 days after the
tragic accident sadly the former co-star
then revealed the troubling final text
message that he received from Dunn on
the night of the faithful crash it read
stopping for a beer be there when I can
what weighed on marera even further was
the fact that he had been in a similar
accident with dun 15 years prior he
recalled that in 1996 marera flipped a
car several times on the same stretch of
road and Margera considered himself
lucky to have survived red fox was a
celebrated comedian best known for his
1970s sitcom sford and Son The prominent
stand-ups influence can still be seen in
comedy today thanks to his long
illustrious career and many catchphrases
in 1991 the seasoned 68-year-old actor
plotted a television comeback and began
work on a new sitcom called the Royal
Family however he died before the series
could air under extremely unfortunate
and unforeseen circumstances box
suffered a massive heart attack while
rehearsing for the upcoming sitcom his
co-star and friend of over four decades
Delice was caught off guard by the
Genuine Health troubles as Fox would
often fake heart troubles while grabbing
his chest and joking that he was having
a serious health scare oh this the worst
one I ever had son oh it's the worst one
this is a big one Reese told jet that
fox was already doing bit when the heart
attack struck so she assumed his actions
were purposeful sadly red fell to the
floor and unable to adhere to Witnesses
requests that he' get up he uttered his
last words I can't breathe award-winning
actor John Ritter was a star of movies
and television in the legendary sitcom
3's company Ritter played the lead role
of Jack Tripper for more than 170
episodes alongside a slew of other
television appearances the actor was
still at the top of his game in the
early 2000s as the dad in eight simple
rules for dating my teenage daughter
tragically Ritter died abruptly in 2003
while filming the sitcom much to the
shock of co-star kayy quo who would
later go on to play Penny on The Big
Bang Theory remembering her onscreen
father quo spoke about her time filming
eight simple rules with Ritter on the
15th anniversary of his passing she
admitted that even though many years
have gone by since his death her love
for the actor is still strong in her
final moments with the sitcom veteran
quok asked Ritter how he was feeling
having heard he was sick in a very
fatherly manner he set quo down and told
her he loved her and I was like I love
you too silly man he goes no I want you
know I love you I said I love you too he
goes That's it the pair then embraced
and that was the last time they would
interact famed actress Natasha
Richardson was the daughter of Emmy
awardwinner Vanessa Redgrave and a
member of England's Redgrave family
Dynasty Richardson made a name for
herself in films such as Gothic and the
handmaids tale before meeting the love
of her life Liam niss during a Broadway
production of Anna Christi in 1993 their
relationship quickly flourished and they
would go on to collaborate on further
projects and welcome two children
unfortunately in 2009 the actress
suffered a fatal head injury during a
skiing accident in Quebec Canada years
later during an episode of 60 Minutes
Nissan shared the harrowing final
moments he spent with his wife before
being taken to the hospital with a
significant blood clot Richardson told
him oh darling I've taken a tumble in
the snow when Nissan arrived to be
beside his wife Richardson was no longer
conscious and her husband was forced to
make a difficult decision he explained
to 60 Minutes that he and Richardson had
promised if either was ever in a quote
vegetative state their partner would
take them off life support niss honored
his wife's wish and recalled to 60
Minutes that he informed an unresponsive
Richardson of his decision though he was
unsure if she could hear him a stand-up
comedy Legend Bob Saget is best
remembered for his work in television
kids I'm going to tell you an incredible
story he provided the narrating voice of
Ted Mosby for more than 200 How I Met
Your Mother episodes and hosted nearly
another 200 episodes of the video clip
series America's Funniest Home Videos
still sagot remains most famous for his
role as Danny Tanner on the long running
sitcom Full House and its sequel series
Fuller house while the characters of
Full House learned how to become a
family through eight seasons the
performers playing the roles created
their own lifelong connections sad L
Saget's January 2022 passing helped
audiences realize just how close the
actors of Full House were many of his
co-stars spoke out about the
interactions they had with Saget late in
life but his on-screen daughter Candace
Cameron Bay's recollection was
particularly touching speaking with
today Cameron Beret recalled that she
and Saget had plans to meet up shortly
before his passing but a delayed flight
and a small argument prevented them from
meeting the next day Saget sent her a
long heartfelt message expressing the
Deep effect ction he had for his co-star
he rounded out the text with the words I
love you more for the trouble you're
giving me if that's even possible
without question Elvis Presley ranks as
the biggest rock star of his time and is
often regarded as one of the most
influential people of the 20th century
the hip shaking singer became an
international sensation for his
groundbreaking best-selling music that
crossed multiple genres launching to
stardom in the mid1 1950s Presley
dominated the charts until his shocking
death in August 1977 although his
influence is still felt today during
Presley's revolutionary career audiences
all over the world clamored to see the
king of rock and roll perform his
natural Charisma helped him make the
transition into acting and he quickly
emerged as one of Hollywood's biggest
movie stars between 1956 and 1969
Presley starred in 31 feature films
ranging from westerns to romances that
almost always included original musical
numbers some of his most famous roles
involved the utopian Island backdrop of
Hawaii which is where he met co-star
Irene Sue on the set of 1966's paradise
Hawaiian style speaking with Fox News
Sue recalled that they formed a close
Bond on set sharing interests in
spirituality and martial arts however it
was her last interaction with the King
that resonated most for the actor she
recalled he just looked at me and said
keep that light burning baby and that
was it I guess he lost his light
couldn't find his way home you know I
truly feel he just worked himself to
death it was very tragic an icon of
class Cinema Humphrey Bogart helped
Hollywood become what it is today thanks
to performances in Timeless films such
as Casablanca the maltes Falcon and the
African queen in life he was responsible
for one of the most iconic lines in
cinematic history he's looking at you
kid however as important as he was to
the film industry the same attention
would be given to his longtime wife and
Superstar actress Lauren ball the pair
met on the set of Ball's first film To
Have and Have Not and despite a 25-year
age Gap they hit a it off they married
soon after and went on to co-star in
several movies including the big sleep
and kargo Bogart and Ball's marriage
remains one of Hollywood's truest love
stories the hardened Bogart reportedly
shed tears the day he wed his Young
Bride and they remained happily together
until his health deteriorated Bogart was
ill for the last few years of his life
but he had ball and many celebrity
friends at his side a long-standing
rumor suggests that Bogart's final words
were I should never have switched from
Scotch to martinis which sounds very on
brand for the actor's witty venacular
however it is better documented that
Bogart spoke last to his wife telling
ball goodbye kid hurry back the actress
reportedly left his bedside to attend to
their children but Bogart slipped into a
fatal coma before she could return no
one can deny Shan Connor's impact on
Cinema the former James Bond actor's
Monumental career spanned more than half
a century he collected plenty of awards
and acclaim while performing in numerous
beloved films including Highlander the
hunt for at October and Indiana Jones in
the Last Crusade the celebrated actor
retired in the mid 2000s turning down
substantial roles in both the Lord of
the Rings and Harry Potter franchises
thankfully Connor reportedly enjoyed
retirement until his October 2020
passing at the age of 90 Connor's Legacy
made a lasting impression on many
performers including his co-star from
The Untouchables Andy Garcia Garcia who
has had a more than illustrious career
himself wrote an article for The
Hollywood Reporter in memory of his old
old friend days after his passing he
even called connory his inspiration for
becoming an actor regrettably Garcia
noted that he had not seen his co-star
and hero for many years before connory
passed despite an open invitation he
wrote about the last time they saw each
other at an event for the American Film
Institute recalling we had a cocktail or
two and it was a beautiful thing he
lived in the Bahamas he said come to
Nassau we'll play some golf Garcia never
did take him up on that invitation and
he wrote that he continues to regret it
with a personality even larger than the
characters that he portrayed on
television Leslie Jordan was a beloved
public figure until his Unexpected death
in October 2022 small in stature and
speaking with a thick Southern draw
Jordan was easily recognizable in his
onscreen appearances some of his most
notable work includes appearances in the
American Horror Story franchise a
recurring role on Boston Legal an Emy
award-winning guest spot on the NBC
sitcom Will and Grace and the show he
co-star on at the time of his death call
me Cat in addition to his TV work the
performer gained a significant social
media following thanks to his comedic
posts during the covid-19 pandemic
Jordan's passing at the age of 67
shocked his fans friends and co-stars
actor Max Greenfield best known for the
sicom new girl shared a long friendship
with Jordan after the pair met on the
set of Will and Grace in 2017 Greenfield
missed his last opportunity to see his
former co-star just days before Jordan
died in an interview with e newss he
explained that Jordan attempted to visit
him during a soldout book signing
Greenfield recalled he texted me during
he was like I saw I tried to get in I
saw that you look so famous they
wouldn't let me in they turned that
turned my little away a pure film and
music Dynamo Australian actor and singer
Olivia Newton John had a fruitful career
in both Industries as a singer
songwriter she scooped up four Grammy
Awards dished out a collection of top
100 singles and landed the top entry of
Billboard's greatest of all time songs
of the'80s with physical meanwhile in
Hollywood she most memorably starred as
Leading Lady Sandy in the 1978 musical
sensation Greece opposite A young John
Travolta sadly the Superstar passed away
in August 2022 and the impact was felt
worldwide unsurprisingly her former
Greece castmates felt the loss heavily
with many paying tribute to their late
co-star however it was her pink lady
cohort DD KH who played Beauty School
Dropout Frenchie who got to have a
heartfelt last conversation with Newton
John the par had remained in contact
throughout the years speaking regularly
up to Newton John's final few weeks KH
explained to page six that they had
their final conversation while her
friend was in the hospital despite her
condition Newton John thoughtfully spent
most of the chat concerned about KH who
had also been sick she even sent her old
friend flowers the very next day passing
on shortly thereafter as 1/4 of The
Beatles John lenon is overwhelmingly
recognized as a musical sensation for
the Maj majority of the 1960s lenen and
his bandmates reigned Supreme Over the
music charts becoming the most
influential music group of all time what
some fans may not realize is that the
Beatles briefly parlayed their Fame into
Hollywood stardom during the height of
beetle Mania the legendary rock group
topl Lind two comedy films a heart day
night and help and they almost starred
in their own version of Lord of the
Rings of course the Beatles separated in
1970 10 years before John Lennon was
murdered outside his Manhattan apartment
bandm made PA McCartney has openly
admitted that he was heartbroken that he
could never fix things with his old
friend saying to Playboy I do feel it
was sad that we never actually sat down
and straightened our differences out
however McCartney confirmed that the two
were on good terms before Lennon's
passing the PA spoke on the phone and
they had a pleasant conversation about
their families Paul was happy to hear
that his old friend was enjoying life
and making plans for the next steps in
his career sadly those plans would never
come to fruition and any chance at a
Beatles reunion was snuffed out on that
fateful December night in 1980
unmistakable as gangster Henry Hill from
the film Goodfellas Ray Leota
nevertheless established an accomplished
career Beyond mobster Flix speaking with
Long Island weekly Leota expressed that
he tried his hardest to appear in as
wide a variety of projects as he could
which manifested in him starring
alongside the Muppets and portraying the
likes of Frank Sinatra so it is
unsurprising that Leota opted to take on
a role in one of the most outrageous and
original films in recent years becoming
the villain Sid white for the
rambunctious cocaine bear tragically it
was one of the last projects Leota would
finish as he passed away in May 2022
before the film even opened before Leota
wrapped up his work on the drug infused
bear movie he offered some touching
words to his friends and castmates the
film was directed by Elizabeth Banks who
previously shared the screen with Leota
in the details Banks remembers her last
interaction with the actor before he
departed for another film set in the
Dominican Republic she told USA Today
the peir hugged and Leota expressed his
pride in the outrageous movie they had
made Banks also recalled another one of
their last interactions in which he
complimented the performance of his
cocaine bear co-star Alden Aron Reich
known for hosting the Weekend Update
segment of Saturday Night Live comedian
nor McDonald was taken long before his
time McDonald elicited laughs with his
ability to crack even the most sarcastic
comments without breaking and has gone
down in history as one of the greats in
the eyes of many of his peers the folky
funny man went on to star in movies like
dirty work and Dr dittle as well as star
in his own self-titled ABC sitcom the
norm show sadly the actor hid his
terminal illness from everyone but his
closest Circle and died in September
2021 nor McDonald's death devastated the
comedy community many of his peers
shared their condolences on social media
one of his closest friends was Bob Saget
who had performed with a comedian many
times and even directed Dirty Work in a
statement posted to his YouTube channel
he recalled that he could tell something
was up with McDonald in the weeks
leading up to his passing Saget recalled
that shortly before his passing McDonald
texted his old friend to ask how he was
doing Saget sent a brief reply and got
another text a week later this time it
simply said I love you Saget replied in
kind and the news of McDonald's passing
broke just Days Later fans of romantic
comedies will remember the 1987 film
Moon struck well the MGM hit starred
singer share as a woman falling in love
with her fiance's Brother played by
Nicholas Cage the movie collected six
Academy Award nominations winning one
for shar's leading performance and
another for supporting actress Olympia
dukas's performance as shar's onscreen
mother both actresses would continue
their successful careers while
maintaining a friendship to the end
Dukakis became a regular in television
films and miniseries building a
significant filmography and earning
several Emy Award nominations along the
way sadly she became severely ill and
passed away in May 2021 at the age of 89
she was quickly honored by her former
castmate posting to her social media
share recalled how often she and dukus
laughed together and how fondly dukus
spoke of her husband Louis zorich Sher
went on to reveal that she had spoken to
dakus while she was in hospice while the
older actor was struggling to hear or
speak at the time a conversation with
Sher seemed to perk her up Sher recalled
in a tweet that she told her old friend
she loved her and a gradually weakening
Duca managed to say it back best known
for his starring role in the first four
seasons of the musical sitcom Glee Cory
montith was a Canadian actor on the rise
before he tragically died in 2013 his
passing was full of Sorrow closely tied
to his onscreen romance mon teth met his
longtime girlfriend Leah Michelle on the
set of Glee where each played the
other's romantic interest break a leg I
love you their offscreen relationship
became one of the most heartwarming
stories of love in Hollywood Monte's
Unexpected death hit his co-stars hard
but they found the resilience to deliver
a tribute episode to the actor in the
fifth season of Glee Michelle dealt with
the loss of her boyfriend and co-star in
a creative way the actress and singer
wrote multiple songs about Monte and she
told 17 that one such track if you say
so was about the final words they shared
as she explained there are lots of
different emotions if you could see this
person again what are the things you
would want to say to them it's a
personal story in terms of what they
asked actually said to each other the
lyrics suggest that montith told
Michelle he loved her and then Michelle
responded by saying she loved him even
more according to the song Monte then
uttered the titular phrase if you say so
for anyone who owned a television in the
'90s and early 2000s Steve Irwin is an
unforgettable figure suited up in his
tan shirt and shorts Irwin was the
premier Wild Life educator and
television personality known as the
crocodile hunter with a heart of gold
and a deep appreciation for all animals
Irwin especially focused on the
conservation of Australian Wildlife as a
zookeeper and longtime host of
environmental documentaries often
sharing the screen with his wife Terry
Irwin the pair became International
celebrities hosting a slew of zoology
programs and specials Irwin brought
zealous enthusiasm and unadulterated
passion to everything he accomplished
until September 2006 when he died during
an accident involving a stingray while
filming a new documentary although his
admiration for reptiles was evident from
his presentations so was his love for
his family especially his wife Terry and
their children sadly the crocodile
hunter had a sense his time was short
and was considering retirement in his
final days as Terry Irwin said on the
Australian broadcasting corporation's
brush with Fame I remember him saying to
me I don't think I'm going to film
anymore I think I'm just going to spend
time with my kids the last thing Irwin
said to his beloved family was goodbye
as he waved to them as they boarded a
flight to Tasmania while he remained
behind to begin filming his final series
veteran actor Scott Wilson amassed film
and television credits dating back to
1967 despite earning a Golden Globe
nomination for his supporting role in
the 1980 film The Ninth Configuration
Wilson struggled to find much notoriety
in the acting game until late in life
the Aging performer finally found
success and fame when he joined the cast
for the second season of AMC's The
Walking Dead as farmer and veterinarian
hersel green Main maintaining a regular
role on the series for Three Seasons
Wilson saw his star grow even brighter
in Hollywood and eventually landed a
main role in the Netflix series The OA
sadly it was at the height of his
celebrity status that Wilson passed away
in October 2018 as the shocking news of
his death broke it was almost
simultaneously revealed that Wilson
would return for season 9 of The Walking
Dead the season debuted the next day
with a touching tribute to the late
actor subsequently his co-stars honored
the late performer by remembering him as
a warm and entertaining man in an
interview with movie web his Walking
Dead co-star Norman Reedus recalled his
hilariously touching last visit with
Wilson he's sitting there next to me and
he can't speak very well I looked over
at him and he looked over at me and I go
you're such a and he just starts
laughing reaching icon status for his
contributions to animation and
puppeteering Jim Hensen was the creative
Mastermind behind franchises such as the
Muppets and Sesame Street as as well as
featurelength films like Labyrinth the
voice and performer behind Kermit the
Frog and a collection of other
characters Hensen handbuilt a production
company that made people smile all over
the world tragically Hensen died
abruptly and unexpectedly from a common
bacterial infection in May 1990 his
death devastated the community that he
is credited with creating however the
Muppet man did leave some final words
for his friends in family in the form of
two letters in them he discusses how he
does not fear death but instead looks
forward to having his Curiosities about
it satisfied as well as getting to greet
old friends who passed on before him he
encouraged his loved ones to care for
each other and forgive trespasses the OE
goes on to detail his wishes for his
funeral including asking his Muppet
family to sing happy and joyful songs
always the jokester Henson's final words
are the most fitting he wrote have a
wonderful time in life everybody it
feels strange writing this kind of thing
while I'm still alive but it wouldn't be
easy to do after I go
we will miss you Jim
Henson one of the more recent
heartbreaks to hit Hollywood was
Chadwick boseman's untimely death
recognized for portraying black panther
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe Boseman
was an award-winning actor who appeared
on screens as far back as the early
2000s his death came as a surprise to
most as he never spoke about his
illnesses publicly before passing away
in August 2020 at the age of 43 upon the
actor's shocking death his friends and
co-stars were quick to fondly remember
the Avengers star Josh Gad who
co-starred with Boseman in the 2017
legal drama Marshall had a particularly
special remembrance for his friend
noting that the late actor knew how
important it was to appreciate every
minute we have on Earth Gad tweeted one
of the final text messages he got from
Boseman the message which was largely
celebrating recent rainfall in Los
Angeles read in part inhale and exhale
this moment and thank God for The Unique
Beauties and wonders of this day we
should take a Vantage of every moment we
can to enjoy the Simplicity of God's
creation boseman's final messages about
living every moment fell especially
heavy considering the secrets he
[Music]
withheld